Welcome!
Hi!
So we're going to speak Norwegian ...
And you know this language, because you're half Norwegian.
Yes.
The job you do here ...
There were 9000 children who were considered for this job.
But you weren't one of them?
No. Because I was sick.
But my brother was there.
And ...
So your brother wanted a part?
Yes.
But ...
... after ...
... we had been on a summer vacation in Oslo ...
... HBO called my mother ...
... and said that they wanted to meet Alberto, my brother.
And I came with him.
And they liked me.
And after a few weeks ...
I got the part, and he didn't.
So you had just come with him?
Yes!
And they saw you there?
Mhm!
But what did you brother say?
Can you tell me?
Uhhh ... He ...
Did he become upset or turn sour?
Uh. He turned sour.
He turned sour!
He was jealous of you!
Yes.
But he's okay now?
Tell me, what did you have to learn to do this part?
I had to learn Neapolitan.
Which ... You're Italian?
Yes. But I had to learn a Neapolitan dialect.
But ... Can we hear the difference between Italian and ...
Yes.
In Norwegian, it's:
«Det du gjør, gjør jeg.»
In regular Italian, it's:
«Quello che fai tu, lo faccio io.»
And in Neapolitan, it's:
Difficult!
You're so good!
I have a picture here, that I found from the filming.
... Of you. It's a picture of you with a strange thing on your nose, what is this?
Yes.
It's to heat the nose or your hands.
Oh, so it's a heating pad? Aha.
Why?
Because it was cold!
And I remember one time that was difficult because it was minus 5 degrees celcius.
And we were just wearing sandals and ...
So you were supposed to act like it was warm?
Yes.
When it was minus degrees?
That wasn't easy?
But ...
Had you acted in anything before this, or ..?
No.
This was the first.
But tell me how ...
You receive a lot of praise, both in Norwegian and international press ...
I've read that you're extremely good at conveying emotions.
Even when you're not talking, you're good at conveying emotions.
And what would it look like, if you were to think about something sad right now?
You do look very sad!
The part you're playing is ...
The role you're playing is Elena, who is very timid.
Are you timid yourself?
Timid?
Timid ... Are you shy?
Yes!
You are?
Yes.
But when do you get shy, when are you the most shy?
Now, maybe.
Now?!
A little!
But it's going well!
Yes!
Di you want to become an actress?
Yes.
Elisa, you're going to celebrate Christmas in Norway.
Are you looking forward to that?
Yes.
Because there's snow there!
And my family.
And my grandmother's meatballs.
Meatballs?
Yes!
Thank you so much for being here, Elisa. Thank you!